-Making their
late-night-TV debut,
performing "Belinda Says"
from their critically acclaimed
album "Blue Rev,"
please welcome Alvvays.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One, two, three.
♪♪
-♪ Can't explain
my ankle sprain ♪
♪ I didn't really feel it ♪
♪ New dress
could turn your head ♪
♪ But how long
till we reel it in? ♪
♪ Paradise ♪
♪ And I find myself paralyzed ♪
♪ Knowing all too well ♪
♪ Blue rev behind the rink ♪
♪ I didn't really need it ♪
♪ Circumspect
when you call collect ♪
♪ To see if I would keep it ♪
♪ Paradise ♪
♪ And I find myself paralyzed ♪
♪ Knowing all too well
terrified ♪
♪ But I'll find my way ♪
♪ Moving to the country ♪
♪ Gonna have that baby ♪
♪ Wait tables in town ♪
♪ I know word gets around ♪
♪ Moving to the country ♪
♪ Gonna have this baby ♪
♪ See how it goes ♪
♪ See how it grows ♪
♪ And I find myself paralyzed ♪
♪ Knowing all too well
terrified ♪
♪ But I'll find my way ♪
♪ I'll egress to Inverness ♪
♪ With nothing in my pocket ♪
♪ Belinda says that heaven
is a place on earth ♪
♪ Well, so is
he-e-e-e-e-e-e-ll ♪
♪ And we'll all get help,
paradise ♪
♪ And we'll start another ♪
♪ Li-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-fe ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]